the foundational base of my success
knowing who I am and where I come from I
had to answer some basic questions for
myself Who am I
[Music]
rise and shine
it's an expresso time what's up
elimination it's Evan I believe in you
and this channel is designed to be a
part of your daily success routine so
let's start your day off right together
grab your tea and sip on today's message
know who you are
over to you Oprah Winfrey also if you
want to know what Oprah and other
successful entrepreneurs have to say
about building unstoppable confidence
check out my 250 for confidence series
where every day for the next 254 days I
will send you a morning video or free to
help you build your confidence the link
to join is in the description below I
have paid attention to my life because I
understand that my life just like your
life is always speaking to you the real
work is to figure out where your power
base is for me the foundational base of
empowerment of entrepreneurship of any
kind of engagement the foundational base
of my success of my well-being my
wholeness my everything is knowing who I
am and where I come from
in my living room right now is a
painting that I've owned now for 30
years you can google it it's called to
the highest bidder
and it's at the center of my house and
it's at the center of my house because
it actually is symbolic of the
foundation of not the house but the
foundation for my life the painting is
by Harry Rosalind who was a genre
painter painter in the early twentieth
nineteen century and the painting is
over 6 feet tall and it shows a slave
woman on the auction block
holding her daughter's hand and I cannot
come in the door my front door or I
cannot leave without passing that
painting I am reminded of where I come
from every day of my life and I am
reminded because I never want to forget
it and in my library I have a frame list
of enslaved African American people
remember I showed you who were held in
bondage on various plantations listed in
the ledgers alongside the cows and the
horses and the buggies and the other
property and I passed this list every
day and often I stopped in front of it
and just speak their names out loud and
their ages Jonah's eleven years old
five hundred dollars Sarah 41 years old
nine hundred dollars Elizabeth
fifty seven eight hundred dollars and I
forced myself to consider the absurdity
and the obscenity of prices being
affixed to each one should they be
placed up for sale and I sometimes just
pause before them with a prayer
particularly before I have to make a big
decision about one of my companies or
whether I booth forward or whether I
stay still it reminds me speaking those
names out loud
not only of where I've come from but how
far I have to go because of them and it
reminds me that I am never alone it
reminds me of what I've come through to
get through throughout this journey I
have learned to block everything out and
focus on my truths I had to answer some
basic questions for myself Who am I
no really Who am I what do I care about
and the answers to those questions have
resulted in the woman who stands before
you today a woman who is first and
foremost a mom look I love our daughters
more than anything in the world more
than life itself
and while that may not be the first
thing that some folks want to hear from
an Ivy league-educated lawyer
it is truly Who I am so for me being mom
and chief is and always will be job
number one raise your standard Apple at
the core it's core value is that we
believe that people with passion and not
one drop of most self-worth depends on
your acceptance of an if you liked this
video I want more Oprah check out the
video I made on her and her inspiring
story the link is right there next to me
I think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there I was
raised on a farm with my grandmother for
the first six years of my life I knew
somehow that my life would be different
and it would be better